hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute gibt es ein ganz
schönes video ich glaube es geht jetzt
nur 34 minuten denn ich möchte einen
smoothie machen und zwar weiter vor
kurzer zeit in hamburg auf der messe und
habe da jeden tag ganz vieles musik
gemacht ich glaube ich habe insgesamt 25
kilo obst und gemüse verbraucht und wir
haben jeden tag etwa zehnmal so viel
gemacht immer ein anderer
und ich hab mir jetzt gedacht weil viele
danach gefragt haben was da alles drin
steckt zeige ich euch das einfach in
kurzen videos also ich mach jetzt einen
grünen smoothie und zwar ist so bei
anfängern vor allem ist es besser wenn
man bei grünen smoothies im zweiteiler
grün und drei teile obst nimmt damit der
smoothie eben auch schmeckt hardcore
leuten eben halt bei grüne smoothies
wirklich nur grünes gemüse das ist
natürlich sehr gesund und vitaminreich
das in viele mineralstoffe mit drin aber
am anfang schmeckt es halt nicht
wirklich wenn man nur spinat klein macht
bisher gurke dazu gibt deswegen ist bei
uns auch noch bis mitte august und man
muss sich daran gewöhnen
man muss sich daran gewöhnen genau weißt
du als wir am anfang zu viel smoothies
trinkt da muss man echt ganz auf
toilette also wer verdauungsprobleme hat
und verstopfung hat sollte einfach
smoothies oder muss man muss sich daran
gewöhnen
genau ich sage dies einfach mal kurz die
zutaten für den ihr also ich habe hier
so ein ganz kleines stück ingwer ich
nehme für mich persönlich immer etwas
mehr ich mag diese scharf hier habe ich
eine halbe ananas die halle schon
geschälte banane könnten ebenso eine
handvoll trauben und so ein bisschen
spinat
schon gewaschen und es geht es ganz
einfach zuerst muss ich mal den ingwer
schälen und das nicht komplett die
schale ab sondern ihr reibt es einfach
himmel messer ein bisschen runter geht
auf dem löffel zum beispiel dann habt
ihr nämlich nicht so viel inhaberschaft
anders man kann sie auch daran lassen
das geht auch aber manchmal zur
haltestelle mit drin die nehme ich gern
weg gibt es jetzt in den mixer und da
habe ich schon ungefähr 400 milliliter
wasser mit drin denn ganz wichtig wir
wollen denn ihr trinken
deswegen muss die flüssigkeit mit rein
und weil der inga diese starken
faserstrukturen hat muss natürlich erst
irgendwann klein gemacht werden
und wenn ihr das land soweit habt als
ihr könnt den mixa immer laufen lassen
ich glaube ihr versteht nicht so wild
ist und so weiter geht noch der spiegel
wenn es dann schön frisch gehen wir noch
die trauben mit rein
ich schalte auch immer wieder auf
höchster stufe
zum schreien muss und die banane
und jetzt ist das muss sie auch schon
fertig also innerhalb von drei minuten
und das machen wir uns übrigens
mittlerweile jeden tag denn ich fühle
mich aktiv
das muss echt sagen ich habe es immer
später seien sie komisch aus probieren
ich weiß dass so schmeckt wie jeden
morgen deswegen ihr könnt da erst selber
rein machen was ihr wollt als ich finde
gurke marcel egger die trauben bananen
und die ananas geben hat die süße und
ich bin total gut klassiker
und wenn ihr zum beispiel morgens so
eine große portion macht können das ja
auch in flaschen abfüllen und einfach
den tag über trinken im kühlschrank
natürlich aufbewahrung vorher immer
wieder kopfschütteln weil sich ansonsten
die bestandteile eben wieder absetzen
weil es ja keine konservierungsstoffe
drin sind keine emulgatoren drin
deswegen ist auch ganz natürlich dass
ich irgendwann feuchtigkeit absetzt und
so dass auf bestimmtes gemüse oben
schwimmt schmeckt wie ich habe ich
unterbrochen
du hast mich schon heute drei mal
aufgerufen ich sage schon gar nicht mehr
klasse und jetzt wünsche ich euch ganz
viel spaß beim nachmachen und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten mal wieder
und wenn ihr wollt dass ich mehrere so
ganz kurze videos macher mit leckeren
rezepten dann lasst mir einfach in den
kommentaren
gerne könnt ihr mir auch zb euren
lieblingsmusik unterschreiben und ich
mache ihn das nächste mal auch noch
hinzu die profi aber rote beete karotte
und orange das machen wir